[Music]
[Applause]
there is so much happening in the news
these days that it's hard to keep up
with it all so please welcome one of my
writers namdy with news you need to know
thanks amber scientists revealed this
week that a new construction project may
cause dolphins to go extinct in the gulf
of mexico no no i can't do this right
now hey take it away
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
what was that
oh that that's my personal sandman he's
basically just like howard sandman sims
from amateur night at the apollo you
know that guy who would usher failed axe
off stage in a fun way except my guy
takes away news stories that i don't
want to see
huh
that's
an interesting approach so i skip the
ones that make me feel bad and i move on
to better stories like this one from my
writer ian
hi amber
a new york city-sized ice shelf
collapsed in antarctica recently take
him away
[Applause]
[Music]
what
what is happening yeah that was a close
one they can't just be bringing up bad
news tarek wait so he's just gonna come
take away anything uncomfortable yeah
more news
please um
[Music]
thanks amber
a large container ship that was stuck in
the chesapeake bay for a month is now
free
all right
well in other news a massive container
shortage is currently slowing down the
supply chain and causing issues for
multiple industries and what now
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um the kovid 19 subvariant called
omicron ba2 is spreading across america
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
mortgage rates are hitting five percent
for the first time in a decade and
ah
[ __ ] come on
uh please
please don't make me come back out here
enough
amber you just can't ignore all the news
derek you better quit playing before
before what why
why is he looking at me that way
taylor
don't move and don't bring up any bad
stories
amber i i have to there's a cute card
with my name on it and i have to read it
terrick don't do it
the
the tragic war in ukraine
is a shining light
tarik no
on how racism affects refugees
[Music]
amber just fine to tune out gossip and
celebrity nonsense but some stories are
too important to tune out yes
we don't have to be experts in
everything going on in the world we
don't have to even actively engage in
every single thing but it's important
that we know what's going on around us
yikes
i know the news can be draining and
things get leak but if we don't know
what's going on how can we help or even
be
informed
enough to survive
wow sarah i i guess you got a good point
there
maybe i can find a good balance without
completely tuning out everything that's
kind of unpleasant
exactly amber
let's see the next story we got
yeah all right
sarah palin has announced that she's
running for office again and nope
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you